a while back I rolled up to a gas
station in a superar and start pumping
gas and a kid comes up to me and he's
like hey do you want a free sample of
perfume I was like yeah sure he squirts
my wrist he asked me if I want to buy
the bottle I said no but you know what
I'll give you 20 bucks just for trying
to encourage entrepreneurship and he
says cool do you have 20 bucks in cash
and I said no I have a card though and
he was like okay let me go get the
carard processor so I'm standing there
my gas is pumping and I see him just
stand there as another guy is pitching
some group doesn't say anything for
minutes my thing clicks and I was like
all right take it put it back step in
the car he sees me and is like whoa whoa
whoa bro bro bro I start driving away
he's like hey man I'm about to get the
thing and so I said listen man I'm
driving this car because I sold the way
you're selling I get it so let me give
you a couple pieces of advice if you
want to take it one as soon as the
customer says they'll give you money
shut up the second thing as soon as
someone offers you money always have a
way to process the money third if you
have a closed deal and someone else
walks in you tell the person who's about
to walk in to wait you have the deal on
the table you made all three mistakes
this will teach you far more than my 20
bucks what have ever given you